en algérie ce sont finalement deux mille
trois cents détenus islamistes qui
seront libérés grâce à la décision du
président abdelaziz bouteflika
celui ci a exclu les auteurs de crimes
de sang de sa décision de grâce dans
quelques instants nous entendrons le
président algérien
mais aujourd'hui les familles des
victimes des actions terroristes
manifesté dans la capitale algérienne
faisant part de leurs craintes que l'on
efface trop rapidement par ses grâces
cent mille victimes d'une véritable
guerre civile qui aura duré neuf ans
reportage eric monier christian hottin
c'est l'espoir qui les a menés là espoir
de voir un fils un frère militants
islamistes profité de l'amnistié libéré
aujourd'hui peut-être ou bien demain de
cette prison d'el harrach délibération
jusqu'ici au compte gouttes
elle n'est même pas sûr que son fils
unique soit prisonnier dans la lettre
qu'elle exhibe elle réclame aux
autorités des nouvelles un signe de vie
comme elle le dit sans réponse depuis
gagné nawel vient de passer six ans dans
cette prison elle et son mari militait
pour l'ex office il a été tué elle est
l'une des premières à avoir été libérée
il ya trois jours
nerveuse elle accepte cependant de nous
parler
si je suis revenu c'est parce que
j'attends mes amis dit-elle il ya encore
une cinquantaine de filles là dedans
certaines sont emprisonnés seulement
parce qu elles sont soeurs ou femmes de
terroristes nawel n'en dira pas plus son
frère lui conseille de se taire et les
lois au même moment dans le centre
d'alger 200 manifestants s'opposent à
cette année ce type
la police leur interdit l'accès au
parlement où l'on vote aujourd'hui un
soutien à la politique du président
bouteflika
tous ont perdu un proche dans un
attentat terroriste ils dénoncent
l'impunité l'injustice et un
caporal-chef du trou plus tard de la
marée il a été égorgé il décapite et
judith j'étais devant chez moi puis moi
j'étais menacé oies et ma famille et
maintenant ils vont vous voyez une
allemande ont les droits aux avalats
hinault il nous autres on abandonne
équilibre avec les partis politiques
d'opposition eux sont dans l'expectative
sans vouloir cautionner la politique
présidentielle que beaucoup jugent comme
un cadeau aux terroristes pas question
néanmoins d'apparaître comme des
opposants à la peine